Secondary worlds are fascinating.
It's no surprise that we're obsessed
with them,
that we want to explore them,
learn more about how they work.
Take a look at this app.
Google chrome made for the release of
the hobbit films.
It's a hyper realistic rendering of
middle earth,
far from the sketches of tolkien himself
farther still from the words you used to
describe it.
The chrome program can be considered an
act of world building,
an extension of tolkiens own world,
building in the Lord of the rings and
more intensely in the silmarillion.
There's something so in chanting in the
complexity of his vision,
in its completeness,
in the completeness of the languages and
the fact that they work.
It's impossible when reading Lord of the
Rings,
not to feel that middle earth is
autonomous,
that it exists despite your reading
about these days,
we have our pick of dense secondary
world fantasy literature is filled with
them.
Think of the Dune series or Narnia or
the late Terry Pratchett's discworld
novels.
Think of the race to fill in the
histories of star wars,
in books,
video games,
and new films,
or take the secondary world.
We're most obsessed with at the moment
the world of Westeros in George Rr
Martin is a song of ice and fire.
None of these worlds are our own,
but each is internally consistent and
each has developed audiences that hunger
for the author to fill in the margins,
the gaps,
the geography,
the backstories,
the histories,
and if the author won't,
they'll do it themselves.
Want to know more about correspond or
Darth sidious visit pdf,
perhaps the most exhaustive catalog of a
secondary world ever made.
Why are we so consumed by built worlds
by the act of world building?
Is this a generous obsession or a
dangerous one?
The great science fiction and fantasy
writer m John Harrison once famously
called world building the attempt to
exhaustively survey a place that isn't
there.
Harrison's point is that the world
building of much fantastic fiction which
takes toll keens legendary them as its
archetype,
shifts the focus of literature away from
the act which is most vital to its
usefulness.
The act of reading world building in
this view assumes a passive reader.
It envisions a writer who photographs a
secondary world,
encodes it into language and a reader
who receives this immersive experience
like a film blissfully and perhaps
willingly unaware that the world he
experiences is a rhetorical construct.
The only problem is that all these
assumptions are based on false premises.
You can't encode the world in language.
Readers are never passive.
They create the text as much as a writer
does,
and all texts are rhetorical constructs.
In other words,
writing is always a game.
It's a transaction that emerges from a
writer's implications and a readers.
Interpretive toolbox.
World building fiction seems to deny
this transaction,
replace it with a cleaner one in which
the story on offer is like a clock,
and the writer is like the clockmaker.
The problem is that this kind of fiction
creates a dependency in the reader to
know more,
to know everything.
I feel this way all the time when I'm
watching game of thrones,
it's what sends me online.
Looking for backstories.
Perhaps this is why Harrison's own take
on the fantasy genre is great.
Viera conium novels resists so
forcefully this urge for dependency in
Veera conium.
Nothing is ever the same twice from
story to story.
Names change.
History's changed.
Characters recur,
but it's never clear if they're the same
people you met before.
Like all books,
Vira.
Conium is just some words,
says Harrison.
There is no place,
no society,
no dependable furniture to make real.
You can't read it for that stuff,
so you have to read it for everything
else.
Everything else.
That's the bill of goods.
The ideas and insights that spring forth
from the explosive act of reading the.
For the record,
I think toking did offer that bill of
goods.
He offered a poetic utterance,
a metaphor.
It was the attempt of those who came
after to literalize that metaphor and
dilute its imagery by asking things
like,
what did sal ron look like?
Or just how might an Elf regiment
organize itself.
It's important to note that world
building is not exclusive to fantastic
fiction.
It's a staple of real world fiction as
well,
and indeed the real world.
It's current popularity is unsurprising
given our modern world,
which is its own kind of fantasy.
Indeed.
This is what makes world building so
potentially dangerous.
The world building of fiction only
greases the wheels for it's much more
insidious and terrifying cousin
political pro building the constructed
world presented to us by politics,
marketing,
and the media.
The act of narcissistic fantasy
represented by the word l'oreal already
exists well upstream of j Dot k rowling
or Jrr tolkien.
Neither of them is anywhere near as
successful at world-building as the
geniuses who devised coke or the
Catholic church.
I am a huge fan of totalking and game of
thrones and star wars,
but I'm also wary and worried about a
strain of passivity and people that
world building fiction seems to best
reflect and at worst encourage who we
are is already hugely and powerfully
managed by interested parties all around
us.
Maybe we all at least to seek out
fiction,
fantastic or otherwise.
That's a bit more impish and challenging
that demands our engagement that rattles
our perspective and exposes the false
fronts of the fantasy.
We were born into the world that was
built without our consent.
Hey everybody.
Thanks for watching.
If you want to support the nerdwriter
and help me keep making these videos,
you can go to my patrionPage@patreon.com
slash nerd writer or click an annotation
here compared to as little as $1
anything and everything helps you guys
have been amazing and slowly getting to
that point where I can do the nerd
writer full time.
And that is the ultimate dream.
And I think the best way to get the best
content to you.
I just feel so creative right now,
has so many ideas and I just want to,
I want to devote all my time to it.
So that is why you pledge if you pledge.
And I thank you for it.
Um,
some of the animations in this video.
We're done by the amazing channel Life
Noggin.
This one right here.
They're incredible.
So right now go to their channel,
subscribe and watch their videos.
I promise if you just watch one,
you want to subscribe,
they're so great.
And they were awesome for,
for doing this for me.
And we also did a video for them.
So,
uh,
you can check that out as well.
I'll put the link in the description.
Thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you guys next time.